hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I'm answering the question that
you guys have been asking me for months
everyone has already done their IMAP Pro
unboxings and I've been so excited for
this computer but mine isn't here yet
when they originally announced the specs
there were rumors the iMac pro with 18
core was going to be delayed I wasn't
gonna let that stop me because usually
whenever I get a computer I end up
specking it out to the max because I put
these things through a pretty much a
torture test every single day editing
especially with my macbook pro almost
all of the videos that i edit in the
past year or so since I've got that
MacBook Pro with the touch bar I've
edited everything on that I shoot
everything in 4k and I edit almost
everything off of solid-state drives I
don't necessarily always edit on the
computer because I'm always so afraid of
one losing my computer to the hard drive
space filling up because there is only
two terabytes on there so usually when I
shoot a video what I'll do is I'll put
it on the two terabyte drive because
that's what I'm gonna edit off of and
then I make a backup of that on a
separate Drive and now that I have my
server I basically dump everything on to
the server first then put it on to my
two terabyte drive and if I happen to be
traveling and editing then I usually
like to have an extra backup of that in
case something happened to the drive
that I was editing on
but the question and the reason that you
guys are here is which I met Pro did I
get and if you guys have been following
me on Twitter there was a slight a
little bit of a hiccup in the messaging
of when my computer was gonna be
delivered I got this email it's that
Justine congratulations you're I'm a
parole was on the way and then within 24
hours those hopes and dreams were
quickly ripped away from me faster than
you can say hey dry Mac Pro is gonna be
here just kidding an email had
prematurely went out to everyone who
ordered the 18 core iMacs and it's still
as the February shift Dave what is it ah
my current ship date is February 5th
through February 19th and the reason for
this is the 18 cores were delayed I feel
like pretty much everyone I know that
his ordered one has already gotten
theirs but I was crazy and I went for
the 18 core the 128 gig ram with the 4
terabytes a low state drive that's kind
of crazy because to get the 4 terabyte
solid-state drive which I know most
people didn't even opt for it was like
2,300 some dollars extra just to get
that 4 terabyte drive which makes sense
because it's solid-state and right now
solid-state drives are extremely
expensive but because this computer
isn't really that updatable I had
date it to the max because I feel like
for me this computer is gonna last me
for a very long time I say that and then
as soon as I get another computer you
guys are gonna come back to this video
and it's going to haunt me my words will
haunt me but either way I'm not gonna
sit here and justify why I bought in
over $14,000 computer because I'm not
sure if I'm sane I don't know if that
was the same decision I don't think it
was a very good decision monetarily
pretty sure I probably coulda spent
$14,000 as an investing in a Bitcoin
mining farm but that's another story
my entire life basically revolves around
Apple and technology so for me this is
an investment an investment in my future
an investment in the future videos that
you guys are gonna be seeing I'm still
trying to justify in my mind how much I
spent a freaking computer well guys
that's the answer to your question
that's the I micro that I got I got the
spectat one I'm super excited I'm still
trying to justify to myself that it's
okay
it was an okay decision make sure you
guys come back stay tuned for the
unboxing and you better believe that I
will be doing some tests of exporting
from my macbook pro and iMac 5k now I
know that I don't use premier but I
would love to do some premiere tests as
well because I know I have a lot of you
guys that do edit on premiere of a lot
of friends attending on premiere so I'd
love to see how premiere and final cut
stands up against each other while
exporting and rendering videos across
the MacBook and iMac and the new I buy
pro so I'm gonna stop rambling I'm just
gonna go think about what I've done and
I'll see you guys in my next video
[Music]